The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osu.mit.edu.
AMIT GANDHI: When you have
a group of two or three,
come grab a soldering iron
and your solar cells from me
and choose, like, somewhere
in this room to work.
We're staying here for this.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: Do you want
us to overlay it?
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AMIT GANDHI: Oh, you're not
actually soldering directly.
You don't want to overlay it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: So these three
contacts will be in parallel,
and these will be
in series, right?
AMIT GANDHI: Yes, you
generally want to go, like--
the way you would generally
do it is you would--
so I think it's less
critical that you
cover this entire side.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMIT GANDHI: So you
cover a little bit of it
and solder to that.
And the back is also, like,
all this is conductive.
The only reason
the tabs are there
are because the tabs
are easier to solder to.
And so it's just
more convenient.
And you don't really need
to solder to all of them
individually.
You can only-- like, at minimal,
if you wanted to do it really
minimally, you could
just do a solder from--
a wire from there to there.
And that would work.
Like, that would be fine.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMIT GANDHI: But the reason
that they have a lot of them
is because if something cracks
or something like that, then
you can tell-- if you have
a wire running across,
your wire is not going to crack
because these are fragile.
And so you have more--
you also have more contacts.
So--
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMIT GANDHI: So you should
feel free to wire it however
you want.
And we're going to
test them later too.
AUDIENCE: Is it melting?
AUDIENCE: Grab that [INAUDIBLE]
so you could dial it up.
AUDIENCE: Yeah we
dialed this up.
AUDIENCE: You want to-- can we?
AUDIENCE: Across
these two, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Or do you want us to
cut it off into small strips?
AMIT GANDHI: I'm trying to
think if that would work.
AUDIENCE: Then
connect these two.
AMIT GANDHI: But I don't--
like, I don't know if that would
work.
AUDIENCE: It'd be
a full circuit.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah,
but I don't if you can
do that across a specific cell.
Like, if you like--
that wouldn't work
because I mean,
it would definitely make
sense if you took two of them
and you did one one way
and you did the reverse.
You had them going in two
different patterns on one side.
So you were connecting
positive to negative
to positive to negative.
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
AMIT GANDHI: And then
on the other one,
you were connecting
negative to positive
to negative to positive.
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: Lattice on top.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Lattice on top.
This on top.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
AUDIENCE: It's a very
[INAUDIBLE] on top.
Like that.
AUDIENCE: Do it
on here and here?
AUDIENCE: Right?
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, do we--
AMIT GANDHI: That's how you
would traditionally do it.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: Oh no, it was good.
It was good until [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Can you
use the scissors?
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: That's what
I'm talking about.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I hate that.
AUDIENCE: And then it
tries to burn the button.
Yeah.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: Do we have
to do this side too?
AUDIENCE: You need more solder?
AUDIENCE: Ribbon.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: A little more ribbon.
AMIT GANDHI: So you
should also probably cut
this shorter because this
is electrically conductive.
Even though it's
not tabbed, like,
the entire surface is
electrically conductive.
So if it's touching,
it's going to short.
AUDIENCE: So like,
this part, like, you
only need this one to touch?
Is what what you're saying?
AMIT GANDHI: No.
Well, that is true.
So the thing is
that all of these
are-- like, this is all one
surface that's electrically
conductive.
The tabs are just
there to make it easier
to solder onto or supposedly
make it easier to solder onto.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMIT GANDHI: But the thing is
that if you have two of these,
like, right next to each other
and they're like the backs--
like, there's a wire
touching-- like, this wire is
touching this.
Then you're going
to short your--
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: So you should
just cut that part off.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So here, you can do that part.
All you need to do is from here
to, like, this much length.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: I heard
something crack.
AUDIENCE: Uh-oh.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: Are we supposed
to do both sides?
AMIT GANDHI: What?
AUDIENCE: Like, are
we supposed to have,
like, both sides connected?
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: Do I need
a load for that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMIT GANDHI: You bet.
AUDIENCE: These are
really pretty in the sun.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: So yeah, so when
you're checking voltage,
you need to sort of
do it in parallel.
Like, check it across an
element to see how much voltage
is being dropped.
So in this circuit, the only--
so you have this battery.
This is the source.
And then the only load is this.
And so this is
going to be dropping
all of the voltage that is being
collected by the solar panel.
AUDIENCE: Getting anything?
AUDIENCE: This is
getting a little current.
AUDIENCE: You don't have
any current in this one.
I mean, the--
AUDIENCE: You're right.
Sorry.
2.36.
AUDIENCE: That's milliamps?
AUDIENCE: Volts.
AUDIENCE: Oh, volts.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
we're checking volts.
AUDIENCE: Then you
don't need the--
AUDIENCE: Then you're on this.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because this
becomes, like, the finishing.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so in
that case, are we--
I don't know.
We're going to
still check voltage.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we'll check
the voltage across this one.
AUDIENCE: Got 1.2--
2.4 for the whole thing.
That's what it says.
AMIT GANDHI: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: Nice work.
AUDIENCE: 2.56.
AUDIENCE: 0.58 across
the whole cell.
AUDIENCE: And what
was the resistance?
AUDIENCE: 100 ohms.
AUDIENCE: It should change it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: No, it's
still wired across four,
and it covers one of them.
AUDIENCE: Can we just--
yeah, can we just
go inside and do a data switch?
AUDIENCE: All those
three numbers.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: I guess there's--
AUDIENCE: I don't think we--
AUDIENCE: Oh are
we going to do--
AUDIENCE: On the first
panel, we didn't cover up
a quarter of it.
AUDIENCE: Are we going to
do a cover on one of these?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, basically.
AUDIENCE: Same thing?
AUDIENCE: Do you want to
just cover the quarter
panel for the first one?
We didn't actually do that.
AUDIENCE: Sure, let's do that.
We just covered one entire cell.
[INAUDIBLE], right?
AUDIENCE: Sure.